動画公開完了
[拍手]
減ったなぁ
いっ
[音楽]
あをする生何してるの盲米 c
a まずい
また今度なはい
御所盲コズミ c
ああ
アーモンド先輩をつけます飯いけません
あーまじすかーなるほどあの女子オレオレ
盲コミ c
ああ俺ららめ c コムシェ
パーッ
ああもうなんだよどいつもこいつも彼女とか女とかくだらないことばっか言いやがって
よ
どうせご飯食べた後は一緒にまったりしたり酒飲んだりするんだろうそして p
feat になってなんだよ
やめてよーとか言っちゃこらせその後あんなことやこんなことをするんだろ r や
らしい
はいというわけで今日も動画はここまでですバイバイっ
ok お疲れ様モデルねー
[拍手]
おっん
最近ぞーなんかを
彼女となります100グッキー
まあいるけどいるですかもう一歩いるじゃないですかー
3つモーターでそんなに出会いあります
小空番車そうなないけど今時アプリとかで出会えちゃうでしょ
アプリはてたーーー早い系ってやつですか
上なが危なくないですか俺なんかすぐだまさにそうでこわ意味じゃなくっていけーって
5話
1巻マッチングアプリで普通に趣味の合う子と飯食いに行ったりするからティショット
が登録するから全然安い
なぜですかやってみたら簡単だった2
やってみな
いややんないんですよそれからさっ
[音楽]
えっとをせてもらったアプリなんだっけ確かだ
たっぷりだあった様子これをインストールしてー
よーしよしよしよし興味あるタグを選ぶと趣味の合う人とマッチングできるんだよな
このタグ選びが重要って聞いておいてよかったこれで完了
う
何この子えっこの子が登録して出てきてるの
ウソでしょかわいすぎなんですけどえっ
ですよこんなのいいかもに決まってんじゃん
やっても緊張するなぁどうしよう
あれ
何か間違えていいかも落ちちゃったえっ
どうしよどうすればいいのこれわかんないえっなんか怖い
どうしよ
あああーー a
通す4 a
a
[音楽]
ええん
yeah
[音楽]
えっ
たっぷるーんだんじゃーん
していた
i am
あれからやりとりを重ねる
沢山の共通点や趣味が合うことがわかっ
そしてついに今日ここやだねーちゃんとデートすることになった
ねっ
でもちょっと待ってー
タップのさせしか見たことないからちょっとわからか不安だぞ
写真がかなり加工されてたらそもそも化粧とか髪型でさあ
だいぶ雰囲気と変わっちゃうよね女子ってうわぁどうしようっ急に心細くなってき
ちゃった
強い強いああああ
あの人こっち見てるなうぽつ向かってるねこれ着てるねー
ああ来てますね来てますねーもう始めますね
うおおおおおお違う人かよ恥ずかしい
もうそろそろ待ち合わせ時間だどうしようマジでわかんねー
yeah 実際に見るとやっぱ背が高いですねぇ
はじめまして主のもなんか変な感じですけど君の3可憐です
大炎上
この子はまさにこの地上に降り立った
炎上
やばいやばいぞ可愛すぎるぞー
入っ
あの大丈夫ですか
大丈夫
あ枝です
本日はよろしくお願いします
やっぱり面白いですね一さん
本日はよろしくお願い致します
じゃあ早速行きましょうかうん
[音楽]
すごい件 none
yeah
入ってず年が動いん
めっちゃ国をするね5位
なんだこの状況はこれは夢ですか
夢なんですかこんな可愛い子と正続がのれデートしちゃってますけど
お願いしますこれが夢なら一生食べないでください
ってかカレンちゃん変わりすぎだろ本当に俺と同じ種族なんですか
このデータをきっかけにどんどん仲良くなって将来的
に付き合ったり結構いやいやいやいや
落ち着き始めまずはこのデート上なくこなさなくては
あれば何処動い古木行くのどこを待ってから選んだ
[音楽]
めっちゃミッシー方法
さっきからカレンちゃんに引っ張ってもらいっぱなしだなぁ
ここは何か男らしい気の利いたこと
カレンちゃん喉乾いた俺なんか買ってくれよねやつですねそこで待ってて
何がいいです私はブラックコーヒー件ならなんでも大丈夫です
ok
[音楽]
よっぺお姉さんまず景気まぶすね
今何してですか俺達と遊びませんか
はっはっは
やばいこれは非常にまずい状況だぞ
なんかすっげーから悪いのに絡まれてるじゃんこれはすぐに助けないと
あーでも強いよう
誰と来て
いつもだちつ
友達
まあまあそうか別にまだ付き合ってるわけじゃないし別にいいけど
村主配布助けなくちゃあーもう
お待たせ排除する
あれ知り合いんうーん
急に話しかけられてしつこいです
タップ google のひょろひょろじゃねえやー
てかお兄さんは out of 韓中だから
ん
が入ってもらえるんです
あの草付き迷惑です
これ以上続けるようでしたらこちらも系 b さん呼びますよ
それでも続きますか
もう諦めてください
僕の彼女なんで
毒制圧だなぁ
の行こうぜー
大丈夫ん
はい
ありがとうございます
よかった
そっか就活かー
カレンちゃん大学3年生だもんねー
はいん
ごめんなさいアップルでは趣味の話とかしかしてこなかったのに急にこんな私のこと話
だ
全済車嬉しいよ
あんまり良いアドバイスできないけど端席くらいだったらできるか
時期的に私の周りの子たちはインターンに参加したりもしてて
そっかそんなん席だもんねー
本当
私も就活頑張らないといけないんですが
うまくいってないな
実は私ずっと留学したいと昔から思ってたんです
ただ家は裕福ではなくて大学費用だけでも流芯に負担をかけてしまってる中
道
言えなくて
a子や
この子はエンジェルやでいい
枚ともしてお金貯めをと努力はしたんですけど
親のお金で通いているので大学疎かになって絶対できなくて
あまり
食べれなくて
出す金ならいくらでもお兄さんが出してあげたい
いやでもきっとそれをやっちゃダメだな
俺もちょっとだけ留学言ってたことがあるんだけど
なんというかこう視野が広がるんだよね
語学だけじゃなくて
人として平蔵できるっていうか
なんかこう今まで人生でさ
当たり前だと思ってたことが全然当たり前じゃなかったり
もしに行かないんだったら完璧に諦めが付く状況にした方がいいかっ
それたぶん一生つきまとってくるしほらあの時行けばよかったなぁって絶対王妃が来る
からっ
その事って親には話したん
まだです
だったら一度本気に話してみなよ
メイヤー飾るとかは置いといてさ
今カレンさんが思っていることとか
頑張りたいと思う気持ち1回伝えてみた方がいいと
絶対後悔する日が来ると思うからん
はい
私この後パパとママに話してみます
この後
今日はありがとうございましたうん
頑張ってね
この後一緒にご飯食べるはずだったのになぁ
来月から留学できることになりました
まずよかったじゃ
に一さんのおかげですまた進捗ありましたら連絡しますね
分かった頑張ってねじゃあねっ
綾部完全に付き合うとかそういうのじゃなくなった
君の運命の人ほぼ苦じゃない
あーづらいけど辞めなん
[音楽]
お出かけってなんだ
なんか場所が書いてあったりデート内容が書いてあるなぁ
えっ
今日明日のデートじゃないかこれうそ
えっマッチングすれば即デートなの
[音楽]
goo
嘘だのタップ嘘だと言ってくれよえっうまく成立すれば今日の夜にはこの人とご飯
デートできるの
やばいやばいやばい落ち着きはじめまだ何も確定したわけじゃない
a ダメでもともと入っちゃえ
はぁ
ua マジかよなにこのスピードカーン
この後俺見堂地さんと二人でゴハンデートするなんでよし
今回は前回から学んでお互いの服装とか特徴を共有しているから失敗はないカメラマン
さんが言ってたな
気軽に食事とかするって気を張りすぎるなはじめん
落ち着け
相手は年上だ余裕のあるところを見せないと
なめられてしまうからなぁ
こんにちは
たお米中驚かせちゃいました家大丈夫です
とはじめです江戸始めです
とっ
みぞおちさん
ミードうちーです
やっちまったぁー
珍しい名字で覚えるたびにみぞおちに増資みたいなことって覚えてだせって言って
しまった
終わっためっちゃ怒ってる
ととりあえず謝らなくちゃ
あのすみませんわざとじゃないんで
覚えづらいから水を家で覚えてついつい入っちゃったんでしょ
はいそうです
ああああああ
買う前にあるんだよねいいよ全然気にしてないから
逆にちょっとからかってごめん
i えっても悪いのは僕なんで
一君結構可愛い顔してたん
お姉さん県ときちゃっパー
じゃあそれじゃあまいりましょうかはいっ
完全にマウント取られたどうしていつも俺はこうなんだ
ああいい一君ラインしてんの
お姉さんお腹が空いたので早くご飯が食べたいです
完全に上手だな余ってくださーーい
それじゃがんぱぱーいっ
[音楽]
風疹
あの
御存知さんってあげ軽いやっぱ
じゃあれ母さんって看護師さんなんですか
あのタップのプロフィールに書いてあってうーんそうだよ
いやすごいなぁ
人の為に作って仕事じゃないですか
夜勤とかもあるから結構ハードワークできますけど
確かに大変なのかもしれないけど
好きで昔からなりたくてやってる仕事だからなぁ
別に大変だろうが私は何を文句ないかな
むしろやりたい仕事ができていることが幸せだし感謝してるよ
ほんと友人学者なんだ
でも一君の仕事も人のためになってるさ
あーやー
僕のはどうなんでしょうだってたくさんの人を笑顔にしたり楽しましてるわけでしょ
それはテレビや映画とか劇とかこうさあとみたいなエンターテインメントを作り出し
てるわけじゃん zepp すごいことだと思う
活かそう俺らにちゃいますよ
いやでも世間から見るとやっぱりこう
音が好きがって遊んで楽してお金儲けてるって思われがちっていうか
なんかそうやって思ってくれる人がいてちょっと嬉しかったです
どうしてもネガティブなものって目につきやすいけどライブ分の1がわかってると思う
よ
自分にはできないから悔しくてそういうこと言っちゃってるだけだと思う
小川に勝利方についてきます
図2位てきますああ
なんか b かさんってすごく優しくて包容力があるなぁ
自分のタイプってこういう子だって君つけてたけどこうやって人と話すといろんな自分
も見えてくるのかな
に換算
あなたは僕の目指すです
分かって全然違和感ないよ
いやいやだから
メカさんは本当に素敵な人です
私が素敵なんかじゃないや
はいなんですかあーんなんでもないん
始め燻っぱらっちゃってるし帰ろっかいやいや僕はまざまな飲めますですよ
ブーブーヤード4番望みますません
山田延ます何ガラス o 酔っ払ってるアート500嫁 a
汚泥さんと黄色がきれいだはだめよだめですかを以下メッセ
a なもののメルシー述べない米バー
ねはい
さっきはすみませんでした
少し歩いたら酔いが覚めてきました
別に謝ることじゃないよ
私も今日はすーっごい楽しかった
あの
りかさんは素敵な人ですよ
僕が保証します何が聞こえてたんじゃんすいません
一君は知らないでしょ
私のこと何も
だからそんな保証するとか言わないで
それじゃあ私帰るね今日は楽しかったっ
ありがとう
カーズ
love まずでが気じゃねーか俺適格者いたのにこれで終わりでいいのか
ここで終わらせていいのか
3かなぁ
何も
俺母さんなこと何も知らないです
今日ここでタップで使って会う前紀香さんのことを何も知らないです
でも訂正はしません
今日出会ってから数時間紀香さん本当に素敵でした
ん
だから次は
会う前紀香さんのことを知りたいです
それがどんなにか3か知らないけど
それでも僕は知りたいです
ダメですか
[音楽]
次
55杯国家はぁ
[音楽]
[拍手]
人は
いろんなきっかけてでや
それはネジで定員と客くらいの関係かもしれないし
まるで映画のような劇的な出会いかもしれん
てやれ
どんな出会いであれであったその後が重要なのかもしれない
あなたは次峰な人と出会うのだろう
[音楽]
はいというわけで今回はですねタップさんともコラボ動画で本格的ていったらいいか
わかんないですけど皆様をつくってみました戦だったでしょうか
たぶん僕がたっぷりあったらこんな感じに動いたと思います
タップば国内の恋活アプリで20代の利用率がナンバーワンのマッチングアプリらしい
です
若い世代の方々に人気のアプリみたいですドラマの中にもあったと思うんですけども
自分の趣味をタグ付けしてこの女が近い人同士でつながるというコンセプトやお出かけ
機能等で気軽に異性の方を誘いやすいアプリとなっておりますでマー坊
ごーなんですけどもなんか昔はねぇ出会い系サイトとかも言われたりしてるんですけど
もまぁこういったマッチングアプリて込んだか怖いなーって思われがちなんですけども
タップがそこ編しっかりしております他人になりすましたアカウント防止のために風
コードの疲れる顔認証技術を使って本人確認を実施していたり
未成年の利用ができないように運転免許
の公的に文章で年齢確認オペレーターの方が目視で確認していたり困ったことがあった
ときにいつでも対応できるように
オペレーターの方が24時間準備しているみたいでございます
それから皆さん安全なんで愛を守ってくれるための体制をかなり厳重にしてくださって
いるみたいですという間もの相続信頼できるマッチングアプリなんですけれども皆さん
ここだ
で合わせないでください今も知らない人と会うことピアノ少なからずリスクは絶対ある
ね
そこだけはしっかり意識していただいてちゃんと利用規約を守って素敵な出会いを
たっぷりで
探してみてはいかがでしょうかそして今だろ得なキャンペーンも行っておりまして
自邸の趣味タグを付けると総額1000万円分のアイテムが必ずもらえる
タプルの秋キャンペーンをやってるみたいでございます海上タグはこちらになっており
ます
僕の好きなターズゲームも入ってますというわけでみなさんぜひこちらを利用して参加
してみてください
投票日
で食べる詳細は動画の概要欄からチェックしてみてください
あの僕もこういう仕事やっててすげー思うんですけども本当にぜ i のない仕事とか
職業あると思うんですよ
そういう人って本当に多分そういう出会いとかで悩むことあると思うんで
こういうアプリ本当に
ひょっとしたら
すごい助かるのじゃないかなと思っておりますぜひみなさん使ってみてください
じゃあ
[音楽]
rel